what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our series on the
Incredible Hulk we're actually kind of
running low on stuff that we're going to
be doing we're uh we're getting caught
up pretty fast with regards to the start
of all-new all-different marvel but this
one is actually really cool this one's
called gods and monsters and this one
deals with the idea of The Incredible
Hulk
lifting Thor's hammer and it's actually
really really cool it's one of my
favorite stories it looks weird though
the art kinda looks like something out
of a on flux shuttle how many of you
guys ever watch that show back in the
day it was really popular back in the
day on MTV but it's still ok you know so
kind of interesting in terms of the
artwork though it's it's kind of catchy
but it's also kind of weird but any
event this really deals a lot with a
character named patty with a character
named Patricia a wool woman I almost
want to say Wolfen with Patricia woman
and what banner does is he actually
gives us one of the reasons for the
character of patty now the other half of
this is the idea of rimmel that at some
point along the line shield was
basically granted a piece of metal by
four either as a gift or as some sort of
study things but the funny thing about
this is that every metal in and of
itself is a very enchant about metal
remember we have talked about the
differences between uber metal vibranium
at a man TM you know adamantium is just
an extremely durable metal vibranium or
at least what Condon vibranium contains
magical properties that basically allow
it to amplify magic as well as sound
guru metal amplifies magic that's really
kind of the extend to it I mean it's
durable insofar is that it's a metal
from another dimension but it's still
pretty durable but the other half of
this is that it also allows its user to
open up portals now one of the funny
things here is that Marvel is going to
delve into the idea of what it is that
allows people to wield force him or in
terms of why it is that a person who
can't who isn't worthy isn't able to
pick it up and it really is just kind of
one of these different explanations
that's given because Marvel's never
really come out and said here's the
unified reason for why it is that people
can't pick up the handler for different
writers do it differently for example
Jason Aaron kind of gave us one
particular idea in the sense of the
hammer sentient another writer later on
down the line may come along and write a
different story on what goes on with the
hammer is really this interesting aspect
and marble comics but it's something
they never fully you know hearken on but
the problem here is that what it is that
the Bruce Banner image guys are looking
for is a very particular material they
can only be access to really only be
gained from the realm of the frost
giants the problem with this is that
anytime the frost giants realized that
somebody has stumbled upon their whole
area when somebody's looking for this
material you know either doom I think is
what it's called or anything else
the frost giants will just kill them and
not really even ask any questions again
they're extremely territorial but it's
also kind of their realms it would be
like a person walking into your house
not asking permission just showing up
you would probably help them understand
the error of their ways and presumably
help them finish with all their living
if you let me Kentucky able to shoot at
you so but the fact your names here with
regards to Thor becoming aware of the
fact that Bruce Banner and as his team
have shown up and Jotunheim or
immediately takes off and tries to help
them out the problem with this is that
Thor doesn't know who they are and
that's kind of an interesting scenario
because it's like well why doesn't Thor
know who they are and again it really
kind of asked us a few questions you
know had they transported to another
dimension it is like another universe
because remember in Marvel Comics you
have the multiverse but every universe
has its own version of Asgard that's the
reason why the ultimate universe had his
own version of Thor that was totally
different from the main marvel universe
version of Thor you know they have their
own a scar behind their own frost giants
all that kind of good stuff so again
with Bruce Banner turning into Hulk and
then fighting alongside Thor the idea is
what in the world is going on why
doesn't throw who they are but in the
immediate it's doing their best to
defeat the frost giants so this is kind
of a funny moment because Thor throws
his hammer and takes that one of the
frost giants and then the Incredible
Hulk picks it up now this is cool
because what this does is it really
shows us an instance on why it is that a
person can lift it in offensive hook for
whatever reason has been deemed worthy
and that's kind of the issue with the
hammer for there's no definitive reason
on what makes a person worthy it's all
contextual for example when beta ray
bill first showed up in Marvel Comics he
was perceived as being a bad guy it was
a ship that was floating through the
solar system Nick Fury at shield asked
Thor to check it out for showed up beta
ray bill thought that Thor was an enemy
Thor was you know the door was a threat
the two of them thought beta ray bill
picked up Thor's hammer only for us to
find out that beta ray bill was
basically this sort of protector for the
last of his race he was escorting them
through the solar system trying to find
a safe place for them to live in so beta
ray bill basically turned out to be a
good guy with the Incredible Hulk he's
not good or bad he's just the Hulk
sometimes he fights on behalf of bad
guys more often than not he fights on
the side of good guys but I mean
remember the enchantment on the hammer
guys the enchantment says whosoever
holds this hammer if he be worthy shall
possess the power of Thor
there's nothing to indicate that the
hammer could only be wielded by good
guys the hammer was always wielded by
good guys until it wasn't so again
that's one of those funny things people
kind of make this mistake of saying what
only
good guys can lift a hammer not fully
understanding what it means when it
comes to the worthiness enchantment
because there is no definitive meaning
to it so again it's really kind of an
interesting scenario here because we
don't usually get to see things like
this the funny thing about this is that
immediately after Thor picks it up the
frost giants start freaking out because
it was like oh my god he picked up that
hammer before but then you know the
Incredible Hulk just kind of gets
whisked away only for us to find out
that Thor had recalled his hammer and so
the question is asked here is did the
Incredible Hulk pick it up or did he
just grab it while it was on its way to
Thor now of course the implication here
is that the Incredible Hulk picked it up
I mean he lifted the hammer of Thor and
I guess we could kind of debate this all
day long but for me that's how it looked
from my perspective anyway when I was
reading it the other funny thing about
this is that when the Incredible Hulk
comes down when the battle is
effectively over when it really kind of
comes to an end one last frost shine it
basically managed to reach through the
portal now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that one of Bruce
Banner staff named Melinda was tasked
with making sure the portal stayed open
so that when the mission of banner and
his team was done they could basically
go back to the portal again but with
this frost giant reaching in while the
portal is closed while it means that
Bruce Banner and his team can't come
back those frost giants also temporarily
defeated but it also kind of stretches
the story a little bit because at this
point now it's how do they get back home
once everything begins to calm down once
the entire event begins to come to a
close what we find out is the reason why
Thor doesn't know who Bruce Banner is is
because of the fact that they're in the
past they opened a portal through space
and time now this is why I don't really
like time-travel when it comes to comic
books for me time travel can be used
compellingly but it's very rarely ever
done instead time travel is usually a
plot device used by writers who just
don't know how to end this story I just
kind of invoking it for the sake of
invoking it now the entire basis behind
this story is time travel but usually
this is that again it could have given
us a far more interesting situation not
only that for whatever reason that I
will never be able to comprehend and I
don't quite know why Mark Waid loves
time-travel but he's all about time
travel and came to conquer this one it's
the ninth wonder of the world
why does Mark Waid love came to conquer
I have no idea came to conquer is boring
to me but the fact remains here but you
know this really kind of sets the stage
for a conversation with regards to Bruce
Banner and his team as well as the frost
giants and sort of you know we muster
their forces and eventually you know go
back in and attack the Incredible Hulk
in those guys again now the other
half of this is the girl named Hattie
the reason why Bruce Banner had brought
her on this mission in the first place
is because Patty's basically dying from
a degenerative brain disease meaning
that's only a matter of time before her
brain he generates to the point this
she'll basically start losing control of
her bodily functions and she'll
basically just kind of die essentially
it's really all that will happen but the
idea of Bruce Banner bringing her here
was to really kind of say look there's a
world beyond what you're used to we can
find a way to solve your prices we can
find a way to solve your problem but
ultimately the idea is that unless you
have a solution at hand I don't care
it's almost granting her you know
wishful thinking the other half of this
is explaining the idea about why it is
that people can't lift the hammer and
its really kind of funny here because
Bruce Banner says well there's two
schools of thought there's the school of
thought about science which basically
says that the hammer was forged by the
dwarfs and it was forged using graviton
particles meaning that when a person
who's not worthy enough to lift the
hammer tries to pick it up the hammer
will increase its own mass now that's
really kind of an interesting concept
because when it comes to like the planet
Earth for example the gravitational pull
of the earth is 9.8 meters per second
squared but if I were to drop you from a
point that's you know from from a high
enough point on earth you would start
falling until you reached 9.8 m/s^2
and then you would actually just get
used to it like you would almost feel
like you were standing still or you
wouldn't really feel that jerking
sensation as you're falling it would
almost be like you're floating and the
world's moving around you at least you
would believe that until you hit the
ground and die but the fact remains that
this doesn't really make a whole lot of
sense
and the reason why is because of the
fact that if the hammer kind of invokes
the gravitational pull of the earth then
it could only weigh so much it's not an
infinite weight it means that you know
it gets on a weird science you stuff
basically would say look I'm going to
keep increasing my mass until the point
that I become you know heavy enough that
people can't lift me but they can't the
hammer cannot become infinitely heavy
the Incredible Hulk
with an infinite level of strength if
you pull it the hammer long enough and
got angry at the hammer long enough he
would be able to lift it if for no other
reason then the Earth's gravitational
pull is not infinite so again it's
really kind of a weird science II sort
of thing at least that's the explanation
that they offer in terms of comics now
in terms of real-life physics I couldn't
even begin to offer you an answer on
that scenario I'm not a physicist but
you know i'm not i'm not a super
knowledgeable science guy but the other
half of this is that Bruce Banner said
is also another school of thought this
says it is just magic as well it is we
can't explain it it's just magic it just
works that way no one
why it just does so again it's one of
these kind of funny scenarios where say
sometimes there is no answer to the
question that we're asking sometimes
that's just how it is that's just the
way it works now following this the
story ends pretty quick I mean it wraps
up pretty fast the frost giants
attacking Bruce Banner and then
heaviness guys you know making it to the
portal that's been reopened by Maria
Hill and Phil Coulson and that's really
it you know they managed to defeat some
of the frost giants make their escape
and everybody just kind of calls it a
day things wrap up pretty fast again
this is kind of an interim story it's
not designed to be like a core part of
what's going on in the Incredible Hulk
definitely just kind of one of those
filler stores which is why the art is so
different from the last issue everyone
the issues that we'll see coming up but
it's just kind of a little little fun
little story about the Incredible Hulk
picking up the hammer for anyway guys if
you are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and let me know down in the
comments section let me know if some
kind of curious do you think the
Incredible Hulk could lift the hammer
for just by pure strength not not even
taking into a worthiness enchantment do
you think that just by strength alone be
Incredible Hulk would be able to lift
the hammer for at some point along the
line I'm just kind of curious what
you're all sought is on that but anyway
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and I will catch you all
later please
[Music]
[Applause]